Les « John » ne correspondent pas à des stéréotypes précis.
Mais, il y existe une vérité universelle :
pas de John, pas d'acheteur, donc pas de victime.
Donc, si nous voulons commencer à annihiler le trafic sexuel,
nous devons atteindre John,
et les entreprises peuvent le faire, là où il travaille.
Il existe une organisation appelée Businesses Ending Slavery and Trafficking,
en abrégé BEST.
Quand ils se sont lancés en 2012,
ils ont fait une étude sur les John de Seattle.
Et savez-vous ce qu'ils ont découvert ?
Les John sont des gens ordinaires, des employés dans les entreprises locales.
Ils ont entre 18 et 84 ans.
Les John sont des pères.
Les John admettent qu'ils achètent du sexe quand ils sont en déplacement,
quand ils vont à des événements sportifs,
ou quand ils sont dans l'armée.
Mais, le plus surprenant,
c'est que l'étude de BEST a déterminé que l'achat de sexe sur internet
est à son pic à 2 heures de l'après-midi.
Cela signifie que ces John achètent probablement du sexe
au milieu de la journée de travail.
Je suis convaincue qu'il y a moyen d'empêcher John
d'acheter du sexe au milieu de sa journée de travail,
et les entreprises peuvent le faire de trois façon très simples.
La première, c'est une politique,
une politique qui dit clairement
que la compagnie interdit l'achat de services sexuels pendant le travail,
à l'aide des ressources de l'entreprise, ou pendant les heures de travail.
Exactement !
Je dis que votre manuel doit donner un exemple précis
qui dit : pas d'achat de sexe pendant vos déplacements,
et au Salon International, parce que c'est là que ça se passe.
Maintenant, une politique n’est bonne que si elle est appliquée et communiquée.
Plusieurs études sur les John ont montré
que le meilleur moyen de les dissuader est l'humiliation publique et la honte.
Donc, les entreprises qui surprennent les John en train d'acheter du sexe
en utilisant un équipement ou les ressources de l'entreprise,
mais leur laisse une chance, font semblant de l'ignorer et ne les licencient pas,
se rendent complices d'alimenter la demande.
(Soupir)
Donc, une politique est un des meilleurs moyens pour commencer.
La deuxième façon, c'est éduquer le personnel.
Les entreprises peuvent faire beaucoup en formant leurs employés
sur les signaux indicateurs du trafic humain.
Là, j'ai découvert la manière dont notre compagnie pouvait changer les choses.
Les autoroutes, les aéroports et les relais routiers de notre pays
sont littéralement les routes de l'esclavage des temps modernes.
Notre entreprise compte plus de 100 000 chauffeurs,
partout dans le pays, partout dans le monde.
Donc, il était parfaitement logique de les entraîner à voir les indicateurs.
Nous ne voulons pas qu'ils s'interposent et règlent les choses par eux-mêmes,
mais qu'ils appellent un numéro de téléphone, la ligne directe,
et laissent les forces de l'ordre intervenir.
Pour cela, nous avons travaillé
avec une organisation appelée TAT, « Les routiers contre le trafic humain ».
Cette organisation, basée au Colorado, avait un soutien en ligne
et du matériel que nous avons donné à nos chauffeurs de camion,
qui leur donnait exactement ce dont ils avaient besoin pour repérer les signes,
comme entendre des messages, sur leur CB, parlant de filles aux sorties voisines,
ou voir des mineures sortir des véhicules
dans les parcs de stationnement des camions.
Lorsque nous avons lancé cette formation,
quelques camionneurs courageux ont admis qu'ils ont vu ces femmes
frapper aux cabines, aux haltes routières des camions,
à la recherche de clients.
Bon, ils ont dit qu'ils n'étaient pas preneurs,
mais également qu'ils n'en savaient pas assez pour téléphoner.
Et c'est ce que nous voulons qu'ils fassent.
TAT, « Les routiers contre le trafic humain », souligne aussi
qu'il faut que les hommes parlent entre eux de l'achat de sexe sur Internet,
et de ne pas acheter de rapports sexuels rémunérés.
Ils montrent des hommes en uniforme
proclamant fièrement pourquoi ils n'en achètent pas.
Pour parvenir à un changement culturel concernant cette atrocité,
nous avons besoin d'hommes parlant à d'autres hommes
des problèmes fondamentaux qui alimentent la demande,
parce que, parfois, les John ne savent même pas
qu'ils achètent des filles réduites en esclavage -
ce qui m'amène à la dernière façon dont les sociétés peuvent aider.
Chaque entreprise possède une ressource particulière ou une recette secrète
qu'ils peuvent apporter dans la lutte contre le trafic humain.
Par exemple, Visa, Master Card et American Express
refusent de traiter les transactions de Backpage.com, un site de sexe en ligne,
dont le commerce de sexe est estimé à neuf millions de dollars par mois.
En avril 2018,
Backpage.com et des sites Internet affiliés ont été fermés,
et le FBI a saisi tous leurs biens.
Pour toute entreprise, engager des survivants est une autre façon d'aider.
Randstad, une organisation qui travaille avec les entreprises
pour trouver des survivants qui ont besoin d'un bon emploi,
a un bon programme appelé « Hire Hope » - Acheter de l'Espoir.
Nous avons utilisé ce programme, et nous savons qu'il marche.
En sus de la formation de leurs agents de bord et de leurs équipages,
Delta Air Lines offre des SkyMiles, grâce à un programme appelé « SkyWish »,
aux survivants, pour les aider à échapper à leur trafiquant,
et retourner au sein de leur famille.
Il y a des milliers de choses que les entreprises peuvent faire.
Ils ont juste à décider de ce qu'ils vont faire pour rejoindre la lutte.
Personne ne peut justifier l'esclavage, de nos jours.
Et pourtant, je pense qu'il demeure
l'une des plus atroce violation des droits civils de notre époque.
Heureusement, le monde des affaires bénéficie d'une position unique
pour aider à former leurs employés,
faire appliquer des politiques,
et contribuer à l'utilisation de leurs ressources spéciales
afin de combattre le trafic humain.
Et vous ?
Que se passerait-il si vous décidiez d'apprendre à reconnaître les signes ?
Que se passerait-il si vous décidiez d'observer les signes tout autour de vous
et de passer un coup de fil ?
Aucune sanction n'est imposée si vous appelez les forces de l'ordre,
au cas où vous voyez quelque chose qui cloche.
Ensemble, nous pouvons tous protéger nos enfants.
Nous pouvons éduquer la population active autour de nous,
et améliorer la société dans laquelle nous vivons tous
et travaillons,
avec John.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)